In France, astronomers have unveiled a
radio telescope that could reveal what's
going on inside an exoplanet. It's tuned
to search for beam-like radio signals
whipped up when a planet's magnetic
field interacts with the wind charged
particles coming from its star.
Astronomers suspect that a magnetic
field may be needed for a planet to
harbor life because it deflects harmful
particles from eroding away its
atmosphere, in particular when the star
emits a powerful blast. The hypothetical
planet on the right, with a magnetic
field, survives the blast; the one on the
left, with no magnetic field, not so much.
The detection of this radio signal would
add a new dimension to the study of
distant worlds.